den heutigen insight geht es um youtuber
marvin der mit 24 jahren einen
doktortitel hat und das ohne auch nur
einen tag studiert zu haben seien eltern
zuliebe wollte marvin beweisen dass er
mehr drauf hat als nur youtube videos zu
machen nämlich dass er auch das zeug hat
zum doktortitel mit hilfe eines hackers
erstellte er eine gefälschte doktor
kunde einer von ihm erfundenen karte
gutenberg-universität die in den titel
doktor der naturwissenschaften verleiht
unterschrieben wurde die urkunde
übrigens von ihnen selbst anschließend
vereinbarte er einen termin im bürgeramt
berlin um sich den fake doktortitel auch
auf seinem personalausweis eintragen zu
lassen
termine bürgerbüro habe ich mich
natürlich vorbereitet ich hab jetzt ein
hemd angezogen mir die haare gekämmt um
mit zwei wochen langen bart wachsen
lassen durch ältere sehe ich habe es in
termine und macht noch mal ein paar
biometrischen fotos von mir
denn die braucht einen neuen versuch zu
machen sie einen neutralen
gesichtsausdruck nicht lächelt jetzt
geht's los
da sind sie die neuen fotos naja
immerhin händler
die urkunde wurde dann tatsächlich auch
für glaubwürdig befunden und der neue
ausweis in die wege geleitet ganz so
cool blieb marvin dann allerdings doch
nicht wie gewöhnlich das stift bin mega
nervös und hoffe dass alles gut drei
wochen später konnte marvin dann seinen
neuen personalausweis inklusive
doktortitel abholen so easy ist es also
doktor zu werden ohne jemals eine uni
besucht zu haben
ich trinke und marvin erzählt wie seine
freunde und seine familie auf den
doktortitel reagiert haben
hallo natalie hier ist ja doktor martin
wild es klingt so komisch aber hier ist
meine person versteht es zumindest
darauf dass ich dr bin auch wenn ich mir
das ganze erstunken und erlogen habe ich
habe ihnen extra provisorisch abgeklebt
für euch aber ja dass das ziel ist
ganzen irgendwie ein bisschen achtung zu
bekommen ein paar komplimente zu
bekommen hat weil ich so wirklich
stattgefunden also überall wo ich den
per sofort zeige wenn ich fliege oder
einen teils bin
das hat nicht so geklappt also keiner
guckt irgendwie auf den pelz und st
doktor wildhagen schön dass sie da sind
also wo es hat eigentlich gar nichts
gebracht
meine eltern sind trotzdem bisschen
stolz auf mich dass ich jetzt dr wenn
die erste doktor einer familie
aber das ganze ist halterung und dann
oben und deswegen auch irgendwie nichts
werde meine eltern haben ehrlicherweise
auch ein bisschen angst dass ich jetzt
juristische folgen davon trage aber
bislang ist noch nichts passieren ich
werde mir natürlich auf einen termin
nach den perso zurückzugeben
aber solang und stehen aber noch mal ein
paar mal vorzeigen und gucken was
passiert
[Musik]